richard thornton offer of the new book
the Nixon Kissinger years the reshaping
of American foreign policy is there
anything that went on during the Nixon
Kissinger years that brought about
either the good or the bad at what we're
seeing in the world today oh I think so
I think in an indirect way or an
important way the debate that began in
the Nixon Kissinger years carried on in
the in the American leadership for
followed some 20 years and resulted in
fundamental decisions about the
deployment of American power around the
Eurasian landmass around the Soviet
periphery that decision as it eventually
worked out was to withdraw American
power gradually piece by piece bit by
bit from that forward position and that
left a kind of vacuum as we see in
Europe and when you have that withdrawal
certainly the reduction of American
power there
that leaves the fundamental decisions
about the the ordering of life and
politics in Europe to others and so what
we're looking at today I think is a
gradual movement by both the Soviet
Union and West Germany to rearrange the
disposition of Eastern Europe is that
good or bad for us well I think it means
we'll play less of a role in in Europe
generally from now on out less certainly
less of a military role we may play more
of an economic role we'll have to play
more of an economical if we're going to
have any influence at all but our the
military days are over your book I
understand is one of three coming out
three when did you finish this one
well it was finished last year it came
out two or three weeks ago who's the
good guy who's the bad guy or is there
such a thing out of your book well I
don't I try to keep some balance in all
this Nixon Nixon Kissinger years is
about is about the the first first phase
of a strategic debate that I mentioned a
minute ago in the American leadership
Nixon wanted to hold on to the
containment structure that had been
traditionally our policy since World War
two and conditions has evolved to the
point where Kissinger believed that
containment was no longer a viable
strategy and argued against it I have to
say on as a side point that it was
rather extraordinary to have an
unelected hired hand national security
adviser opposing the president the way
he did but he did nevertheless and in
effect became is like as I called him in
the book Shogun of American foreign
policy but Kissinger argued that the
United States had to move toward a new
strategy one that abandoned containment
and moved toward a withdrawal of
American power from around the Soviet
periphery substituting it with
collective security structures as time
and opportunity would permit and and
Kissinger won that battle the battle of
course as I described in the book took
place on another field and that is the
field of domestic for American politics
and the battle was Watergate the
president lost that battle and in losing
that battle lost control over foreign
policy so that's that's this the guts of
the argument and this and this the first
volume look the second and third volumes
that follow the Carter years and the
Reagan years
and we'll describe the the perils of
that strategy as it unfolded over the
next 15 16 years let me read the last
almost last paragraph your old book I
guess it is because it relates to things
we see in the news this morning for
instance you see where Egypt now has
diplomatic relationship relationship
with Syria the Chinese students are
making noise again over in China there's
an article in The Washington Post where
China and the Soviets are supposed at
each other's throat again let me read
the first attempt to recast American
strategy as detailed in this volume
failed utterly to achieve the central
objectives that they taught and arms
control the Soviet Union and the equal
liberation of the economic relationships
with Germany and Japan
indeed Kissinger engineered in defeat of
engineered defeat in Vietnam leaving a
permanent scar on the national psyche
turn to promising rapprochement with
China into a stillborn relationship
promoted war in the Middle East badly
mishandled relations with Israel and
turned Angola into a battleground it
would be hard to find a less successful
period of American foreign policy than
the Kissinger Shogunate now there's
nothing but indirect about that it's
rather direct rather direct what are we
seeing today then in what's happening
around the world that was brought about
by either mr. Kissinger or mr. Nixon
that is positive that's positive well I
think the positive side of American
strategy is one that escapes almost
everybody and what I described there are
the initial steps of a movement toward a
new strategic position by the United
States but the real positive side is a
more general argument and that is if you
look back in history and I mean look way
back into history to the dawn of time
arguments were always territorial
those arguments are always resolved by
Wars since World War two the positive
aspect of American strategy and you have
to give that to our leadership has been
to shift the nature of the conflict from
from war to economic contest and won and
that it really is a is a major change
giving giving you a Panama and the
conflicts that go on in various places
around the world
the major conflicts between major powers
that's I think that's crossed my fingers
but I hope that's in the past and I
think that's the major achievement that
the United States can and called it's
its own we've tended to shift the nature
of conflict from military to economic
Richard Thornton is a professor at
George Washington University he's a
professor of history and international
affairs at the Elliot school for
international affairs he's served as a
consultant of the u.s. Department of
State when you do that 1969-70 lectured
around the world for the u.s.
information they didn't see when you do
that
Heath 285 every year retired as a
lieutenant colonel after ten years as a
reserve officer in the US Air Force
intelligence author of numerous books
including China a political history and
Soviet Asian strategy in the Brezhnev
era and beyond when does your next book
come out and that's you say on the
courier it's the Carter years that ought
to be out the next poll in this
morning's Wall Street Journal Alexander
Coburn writes about Panama and the press
and he says the US doesn't care a fig
for democracy in Panama and the
administration turned with reluctance
against general Noriega only in the late
85 and later still found his eviction
desirable as a part of the high public
relations stakes of the drug war what do
you think when you hear somebody say
that we don't care a fig for democracy I
think he's wrong about that we care at
least two things we certainly see
democratic systems as systems which are
supportive of our approach to global
affairs and so we care very much about
about the countries and their systems
after all we spent a lot of time doing
the same thing for the last 45 50 years
trying to install democratic system I
think this is part of the whole effort
of moving away from from resolving
conflicts by shooting people moving
toward them toward economic conflicts
but I die would inton on that I I
certainly think there are important
national security reasons for the United
States to have used its power in this
particular instance they have to do not
only with drugs but with the operation
of the canal itself and so I on the one
hand I I think it was important for the
United States to go in in there and on
the other hand I think it's vitally
important that we demonstrate that the
end result of our endeavor will be a
thriving and functioning democratic
system New York City you go ahead please
you're on the air New York City are you
with us
and here in New York City this morning a
little trouble with the phones lit alone
we'll work on that we got a lot more to
talk about and I hope we get to the
phone sir soon mr. Coburn again
victory bulletins flow north from us
reporters clustered mostly under the
aegis of Southern Command have you got
it have you had a sense that the press
has been one-sided in the reporting
coming out of Panama aye
my sense is that the the press has has
done what it always does there are
always going to be reporters who who sit
around the hotel bars and get their news
stories that way all these other
reporters who get their news stories
from handouts from from the occupying
forces and they're always on reporters
who go out into the field and and throw
it out the nasty side the dirty side of
the war and we saw a lot of that I
thought we saw pre balanced reporting we
saw that good end
bad and the ugly in Panama let me try
one more time even you go ahead please
yes sir mr. Soros I'd like that I'd like
to ask you what you thought of John
Stockwell's program that was broadcast
yesterday over CNN well first of all it
wasn't on CNN it was on c-span but
secondly I'm not sure that the professor
saw it did you see it yeah it was a
program that was broadcast here do you
have a comment on it sir hoarsely he's
going let me go back to you know john
stockwell yes I don't know him
personally I know his work you have any
comment on his work he wrote a very
interesting and informative book called
in search of enemies I cite it liberally
in my book on my chapter on angle in
this book it's invaluable if anyone
wants to look about the origins of the
angle of war look at that you've got to
look at stockwell's
look David he coming on whether he's
right or wrong or he's disaffected
clearly yes that is got his access to
grind but he's written a book that is
extremely valuable to anyone who wants
to look at the American involvement in
Angola in the early days New York City
go ahead please tomorrow mr. lamb
congratulations through your tenth
anniversary thank you
comment to our guests let me ask a
question certainly go ahead please my
name is gregory smith my uncle's Gerard
Smith the first salt negotiator man we
had old problems with mr. Nixon and mr.
Kissinger we worked very difficult and
we worked hard for salt 1 but they spoke
English would you compliment please
Thank You Gerard Smith of course was a
Democrat in a Republican administration
and
that was not necessarily a strike
against him but the way that the salt
negotiations were run then and our run
today is that the essential
decision-making for arms control is done
in the White House
it's not done by the salt bureaucracy
salt bureaucracy works out the details
the White House decides on the big
picture and that was essentially the
conflict between Gerrard Smith and Henry
Kissinger who was of course making those
decisions along with the president at
that time in the White House New York
City again go ahead please hello I want
to know what you think President Bush
and Dan Quayle was doing
Nixon and well while he was in the White
House my initial was in the White House
and what was Dan Quayle and Bush doing
at the time whether they're like making
millions that have like corporations or
what were they doing well I can't speak
about Dan Quayle I'll have to ask
someone else about that but Bush was our
envoy to the UN at one point and then
the game our envoy to through China and
liaison office in there been seven Tulsa
Oklahoma go ahead please but so far it
sounds like the thrust of his idea is
that Kissinger made gross misjudgments
and kind of got us into the soup I have
more of an impression that besides
Watergate which he met she has mentioned
so far that really the basic problem the
whole era was that the Vietnam syndrome
and the anti-war movement typifies by
cbs's selling of a Pentagon which was
horrible travesty
the country just presento mood for
defense to spend money on defense there
was no alternative but to participate
counter delaying action and pull back
around the world
I don't see what else he could have done
I'd like your comments on this place
good question let me describe a little
bit about the book which I am I haven't
done that much about yet by the time
that that Nixon came into power was
elected in 1968 he had two fundamental
trends evolving that that were critical
to everything that would then end soon
the first was growth of Soviet strategic
weapons power by the time Nixon came
into power the US and the Soviet Union
had moved close to an equilibrium the
United States still had an important
advantage in numbers of warheads and
overall nuclear power but the Soviets
had reached the point where they could
already calculate upon neutralizing the
American guarantees to its allies in
Europe and Asia that was the first major
change and that required fundamental
rethinking of American strategy because
after all nuclear power was the anchor
of the forward American position around
the around the Soviet landmass the
second trend was equally if not more
important and that was the rise to
economic superpower status of West
Germany and Japan so on the one hand
while containment was threatened from
without by the growth of Soviet military
power it was also being eroded from
within by the growth of German and
Japanese economic part of the former
Axis powers from now economic
superpowers and increasingly inclined to
go their own way stay within the Western
alliance and under the umbrella to the
extent that it suited them but to go
their own way in economic matters and so
what you saw the Germans and the
Japanese doing in effect Germany began
to buy up Eastern Europe as it's doing
right now and the Japanese began to
expand their economic power mainly by
coming into the American market but
these were the fundamental conditions
that
brought forth the strategic debate about
containment that I described in this
book and while while Kissinger made
serious errors I think in policy in the
strategic judgments I think he was
fundamentally correct containment was no
longer viable you couldn't you couldn't
continue after all half of our defense
budget is goes for NATO you couldn't
continue both in a major engagement in
Vietnam where you had over half a
million troops deployed on the one hand
and on the other hand put half of your
budget into NATO in fact we didn't do
that we we began to cannibalize from
from all of our defence governments
around the world to meet this the
sinkhole in Vietnam that we were engaged
in and saw that I mean you had to change
that you couldn't you couldn't do that
indefinitely you would simply who wrote
the basis of American power we have some
lines open for our guest professor
Richard Thornton of George Washington
University talking about his book the
Nixon kiss new years talking about
foreign policy let's go to Boston
Massachusetts go ahead please in
Cambodia and any comment about what's
happening there now Cambodia was and is
a natural competitive area between
Vietnam and China what what Kissinger
did one of the things that Kissinger
sought to do I call it his the tri-polar
policy but he tried to do was to
perpetuate sino-soviet adversary
relationship and well and one of the key
links in that overall policy approach
was the withdrawal from Vietnam
withdrawal from Vietnam meant that there
were emerged a big Vietnam but more
importantly that big Vietnam would would
be part of the hammer and the anvil
against China with us
a union in the north and a pro-soviet
client state Vietnam in the South now
the only area that meant that that meant
the end of a decade-long Chinese
strategy of attempting to to fragment
Southeast Asia in order to promote their
own preserve their own hegemony in it
that meant the the end of that strategy
I meant the emergence of a major adverse
Iran China's southern border and the
only way the Chinese could hope to
contain Vietnam which is what they tried
to do was by moving into Cambodia the
only only area left where there was a
chance of trying to counterbalance the
rise of Vietnamese power in Southeast
Asia and so you've had that that that
competition between them from 73 on to
the present I were no longer in a
position to to really play a decisive
role there the key fact key actors there
now I think are the Chinese the
Vietnamese and the Russian numbers are
on your screen two oh two six to eight
to five to five if you live in the
eastern and central time zones - OH -
seven eight three two seven two seven
Mountain and Pacific give us a call and
continue our discussion here this
morning on foreign policy South Lake
Tahoe California go ahead please per
capita expenditure on military the
average Japanese citizen is one-eighth -
what it is with their - the United
States as you pointed out the shift is
in the effectiveness of world powers
moving to the economic front to the
military front and I wonder just what
you feel about levels of military
spending in this country given the
changes in the world well I think
clearly levels of military spending in
the United States will go down I don't
think they're gonna go down as many
people would as far as maybe would like
to like it to go but it will go down and
there'll be something of a transfer from
there'll be something with a peace
dividend will see some transfer from
military expenditures into social
welfare expenditures but the the general
idea it seems to me of American strategy
is to try to get German and Japanese
military expenditures to go up so that
there will be some evening out in terms
of our ability to perform economically
and compete with them and this is a
general idea of getting Japanese to to
play more of a security role in the
Pacific getting Germans to play more of
a security role in in Europe we're not
going to be there
the last the last military leverage we
have in Europe is already by treaty
designed to come out and that's the
pershing and the ground-launched cruise
missiles our troops are on their way out
and they they give us no no more
leverage either Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
you're next in 1969 when President Nixon
took office
what is the Vietnam War in your opinion
still winnable and if it was why it not
only was winnable in my view if you read
this book you'll see that Nixon won that
war that's an extraordinary statement to
make because everybody believes the
United States lost the world we didn't
lose that war we decided to withdraw
from the battlefield that was the
function of the Paris agreements and
that was the function of the of the
strategic debate that went on inside the
American leadership when Kissinger
wanted he decided to take the United
States out of the out of the battlefield
Nixon's endgame in Vietnam was to leave
Vietnam in a condition like South Korea
his plan was to maintain an American
presence on the Southeast Asian mainland
just as we had on the North East Asian
mainland and to reinforce that presence
with offshore military power that was
the whole idea of
settlement as far as Nixon was concerned
but not as far as Kissinger was
concerned Kissinger wanted to reach the
settlement and then after what what he
called a decent interval take American
power out and let the chips fall where
they may
and in falling that meant there would
emerge as I said a big Vietnam which
would then be part of that larger Asian
structure Vietnam China and the Soviet
Union so I think it's one of the one of
the gross miss judgments about Vietnam
was that we lost it we walked away from
it didn't lose it Signal Mountain
Tennessee go ahead please yes good
morning Brian
I want to make comment in regard to a
comment that your guests made there just
a moment ago at the mind in regard to
any peace dividend that we might enjoy
from the happenings if we should I would
prefer that spokesman speak in terms of
reducing the deficit rather than
transferring this peace dividend to more
social spending because I think we it's
very important that we get her deficit
down somewhat and then to your guests if
he if he could just make a blanket
statement in regard to the overall job
that as far as foreign relations go with
the Nixon and Kissinger what his his
what is his view as to did they make an
a did they make a B did you make a C and
then compare it to some of the previous
administrations thank you hey beer C hey
beer C a in terms of Kissinger and Nixon
both of them received A's on strategy
these guys knew what they were about hmm
in terms of policies Kissinger gets C
minus because it didn't succeed in
accomplishing what he set out to
accomplish in terms of actually carrying
forth specific policies that were
related to the overall strategy
strategic design that he had it worked
out so you've got to divide it between
strategy and policy they understood the
the conditions the changes that were
occurring in the world how they affected
the United States but when they moved to
implement carry out specific policy that
would and presumably be to the advantage
of the United States
I'd have to say C - or on the basis that
grading system what would you give the
Bush Baker team it's the same category
well it's early and after a year I'll
tell you the the third book in this
trilogy of mine called the Reagan years
the subtitle is going to be the end of
containment embodied by the beginning of
the second term of the Reagan
administration the issues had been
fought over again and it was decided
that there would be no longer no no
further efforts at maintaining any kind
of a containment in any form modified or
otherwise around the Soviet sphere what
Reagan had done in the no and this leads
to an answers your question about Bush
but I have to take a running start what
Reagan had done was to drive the Soviet
Union out of the game fundamentally in
the first term President Reagan rebuild
American military power in a way that
had not been seen in the Carter years
certainly but for many years not only to
rebuild American strategic power and
conventional power he sent the game of
military competition into a new
dimension with the Strategic Defense
Initiative and the Russians found it
impossible to compete on all those
levels at a time fortunately I think for
the United States at a time when there
old economic system fell apart you had
the Russians were progressively unable
to maintain the integrity of their own
domestic political and economic system
and therefore were no longer able to
compete with us on the international
sphere and you have the emergence of a
Gorbachev who recognizes that and has
got to put his own house in order before
he can hope to compete and I'm sure he
wants to compete once again in the
future but not not in the near future
White Plains New York go ahead please
how possible be if you'd read a 1957
book he outlined a plan for having small
units akin to naval units that were self
supportive and would use tactical nukes
in a.m. possible Russian attack on
Western Europe I was learning how
cost-effective would be to defend Europe
in such a manner and whether would leave
an opening for the Russians to use the
same tactics to fight on
well 1957 is his light years away from
today I I don't think that the United
States and the Soviet Union will will
engage in a conflict over Europe because
neither one of us is in a position to to
to do that the Russians clearly are
while they retain significant military
power cannot possibly carry out an
invasion of Europe given the state of
Eastern Europe and their Warsaw Pact as
it is today the United States on the
other hand finds find it unnecessary to
defend what cannot be attacked but more
importantly Germany West Germany is in
is in the catbird seat in Europe today
West Germany
as a criminal controlling financial
interest in both the east and the west
all the currencies are dominated by the
deutsche mark they've got a European
monetary system which which
fundamentally run by the Germans and
they've been buying their way and
Eastern Europe since the late 60s they
are the principal trading partners of
all of the countries in Eastern Europe
including the Soviet Union
West Germany until just a few days ago
was the largest exporting nation in the
world we just surpassed that I
understand a few days ago but it's
closed so you're looking at a superpower
and everything but but military power
today it's an awful lot like like the
Japanese on the other side Eurasian
landmass where do we go go ahead please
yes hello I would like to ask a question
of professors Torrington do you believe
that Kissinger strategy of developing
regional powers around the Soviet Union
contributed to toppling the Shah in Iran
the subject of my second book by Carter
years you can envisage a map of the
erosion landmass you realize that Iran
with its 1,400 mile long border with the
Soviet Union was for a long time the
forward-most position in the containment
structure at the United States built
around the Soviet periphery in the
Carter Administration what what the
leadership wanted to accomplish some of
it was a was a a formal and less less
less close relationship with Iran what
they wanted to achieve was the
redeployment of American power they
wanted to change the nature of the
relationship between the United States
and Iran from from that from that
client patron relationship that existed
up through the mid 70s to one that was
more distant where Iran would play a
more independent role and one between
habit as good relations with the Soviets
ahead with the United States and they
failed utterly and accomplishing that
objective that was the objective that
the Secretary of Vance sought as he says
in his own memoirs swine for Germany go
ahead please
Germany you're on the line go ahead yes
I'd like to ask rather hypothetical
question but since you know the policy
of kissing and there's Nixon very well
considering the euphoria that we have
regarding Eastern Europe and typically
the attitude that we no longer need a
defense in NATO do you think that Nixon
with his employer T that he usually are
consistently maintained regarding the
Cold War and communism do you think that
he'd be maybe a little more cautious a
little more reluctant to build down NATO
then current policy seems to indicate do
you think that that team might have been
a little more reluctant to trust the
trend of events there's been a lot of
talk from Russia about arms reduction
but so far there's actually been no
reductions at all they've just been
spotted enough to call it the press when
they scrap old weapons that's torn the
first question about about Nixon Nixon
clearly wanted to maintain as maintain
as much of a containment structure as he
could he moved toward a modified
containment structure compensating where
he had to for example after the
indo-pakistani conflict he then moved to
build up Iran and build up Saudi Arabia
to compensate for the loss of Pakistan
I think Nixon clearly wanted to hold on
and that was the natural thing to do the
natural thing was was not to cut losses
and Kissinger argued no you it's too far
it's gone too far we've now got to cut
losses so I think an answer to the first
part of your question I think Nixon was
a lot more tenacious in holding on to a
strategy which after all it benefited
the United States tremendously years
after World War two second part of your
question that the Russians aren't in
into perestroika in order to dismantle
their own system they're not into it in
order to become a second-rate power
they're into it into it to become a
formidable competitor on the global
scene they've got to recover from the
economic disaster visited upon them by
the abrasion of leadership but clearly
they they intend to take one or two
steps back make their deals with the
Germans as they are doing now doesn't
that remind you of the period after
World War one and then after their own
Revolution where they had to make a few
compromises temporary compromises in
order to build strength and return on
the on the global scene in force I think
the Russians are not going to to cast
away they're a long term objective of
dominating Eurasian landmass whether
they can do that is going to be an
interesting questions I think the
Germans are now a leg up on that in that
process
published by Paragon house this is the
book the Nixon years
Nixon Kissinger years by Richard
Thornton when we go to Portsmouth
Virginia go ahead please yes I wanted to
ask a professor Thornton if he thought
that the with the rebuilding of West
Germany and Japan their newly found
economic powers if I guess this is the
question of the hour if they're going to
build a military machine again and
become militarily active and if they do
do you think well what do you think
we're what do you think our foreign
policy people are going to do how
they're going to react to it
and what do you think they should do
well Germany and Japan rebuild their
military power absolutely yes the
Japanese are already either number three
or number four in terms of total defense
spending in the world depending on how
you calculate their their effort so the
Japanese are well on the way to doing
that one always talks about the one
percent limit on their spending but when
you've got a GNP as large as there is
one percent a lot though Japanese are in
they have in in a structure they've got
the military they're gonna they're going
to need four though for the long haul
then you just need to flesh it out a
little bit that's also true for the
Germans in fact what I expect to happen
and I'm sure there are lots of
everybody's on the prognosticator on
this but what I expect to happen is that
that we're going to see the
Europeanization of of NATO that's well
long already and the Germans will play
of a substantial role within that Tampa
Florida go ahead please yeah Brian I'd
like to extend all the accolades that
you've gotten over the years about your
great program thank you and I would like
to ask the professor this
I'd like you to if you would sir project
yourself 20 years into the future and as
papers become public property and
everything how do you think historians
will look at the Reagan presidency not
only from a foreign policy standpoint
but come as domestic in every all other
aspects look number three is the all
other aspects that are the that are the
tough parts you'll have you and it's
quite quite partisan that I'm surprised
at how partisan the evaluations of
Reagan have been so far you have on the
on the conservative side of course the
argument that Reagan was the be-all and
the end-all to to American politics in
the 80s in fact Pat Buchanan had a had a
editorial along that line
Washington Times just the other day and
on the Democratic side there are going
to Reagan was to be on the end all of
although all the ills that were visited
upon us domestically in the eighties
well I think it's it's clearly somewhere
in between but on balance you'd have to
give Ronald Reagan a tremendous credit
for pulling the United States out of the
doldrums that were in that we were in in
late 70s under Jimmy Carter who
unfortunately had to preside over a
nation which as he called it was in a
malaise next call Frankfurt Germany go
ahead please you think a policy in the
Middle East wants to create religious
faith to keep communist power out of the
countries surrounding the oil wealth
this policy has proven wrong through
what happened in Iran do you think that
this purchase
till adopted by the Bush administration
if not why religious penalties still
supported by the US like for example the
support of the Syrian policy in Lebanon
restaurant I didn't get all the question
but the part that I did did yet was most
interesting let me respond Kissinger
strategy in the Middle East as far as
the arab-israeli context was concerned
was essentially to take Israel out of
the two front conflict between Egypt and
Syria but to take Egypt out of that
conflict and try to build what what a
later Secretary of State would call the
strategic consensus in the region based
upon an Egyptian Israeli rapprochement
that strategy worked for a time but it
has foundered on the Israeli
unwillingness to trade territory for
peace and I think that that fundamental
unwillingness on the part of the Israeli
leadership
has produced what we saw in the
newspaper today a rapprochement between
Egypt and Syria and potentially the
return of Israel to a two-front conflict
situation 16 seconds left you have a
theory in your book that John Mitchell
wanted to get rid of Richard Nixon yes I
think John Mitchell was the man who
carried out the entrapment of Richard
Milhous Nixon in the domestic political
events we have viewed as Watergate
whether he was a managing director of
that operation what were his motives his
motives were to attempt to provide
policy leverage for the eastern wing of
the Republican Party which Nixon was
supposed to the Rockefeller wing of the
Republican Party Kissinger's part of the
Republican Party and the idea was to
build leverage on on Richard Nixon in
the second term when he would be unbel
allies and supporters but they were law
partners before they got him they were
law partners and in fact if you look at
read Nixon's memoirs he circles around
that possibility that Mitchell was was a
guy responsible for his demise and can't
bring himself to say it publicly we're
out of time and our guest has been the
author of this book the Nixon Kissinger
years in your book stores this is
Richard Thornton's book and he is a
professor at George Washington
University thank you very much for spend
time was we'll be back in just a moment
with Andrew Nagurski of Newsweek to talk
about Romania